[Música]
en francia la capital del chocolate es
jon
[Música]
alberga la mayor concentración de
chocolateros artesanos que compiten por
las recetas para atraer a los gourmets
una de las marcas más conocidas
pertenece a una empresa familiar
filipinas john es el dueño está fábrica
de chocolate la heredó de su abuelo
todas las máquinas son de aquella época
y para él es imposible reclamar el
título de chocolatero artesano sin
controlar la producción de principio a
fin
shuffle se tensó al mundo pero en
realidad fue la elección de mi abuelo
era lo que él quería era para hacer su
chocolate así que trabajo con un
importador y le dijo quiero los mejores
granos del mundo para hacer mi chocolate
así que está madagascar venezuela méxico
colombia perú también gran parte de
américa central
pues realmente quedé atrapado desde que
era un niño
yo solía pasear me por allí cuando
pequeño me hacían saborear yo leo
en el mundo del chocolate la apariencia
es casi tan importante como el sabor
willy ferrier en cambio trabaja con un
mazo y un cincel de chocolate
aquí estamos haciendo una escultura eso
es todo el bloque pesa unos 130 kilos se
puede ver que no es tan duro como la
piedra pero se rompe en grandes astillas
así que hay que cuidar mucho cada gesto
poco a poco la escultura va tomando
forma bajo el trazo del cincel
bueno en una escultura como esta me
gasto unas 60 horas
en esta otra fábrica de chocolate de
lyon philippe to com es el director de
producción su materia prima no son los
granos de cacao sino estas enormes
tabletas de chocolate
y el chocolate aquí está cristalizado se
va a poner en estos cristales a 40
grados centígrados para que se disuelva
completamente y luego se trabajará abajo
en unos 30 grados
no
[Música]
la especialidad de la casa es el praliné
preparado a la antigua una mezcla de
avellanas y azúcar triturada y refinada
a 30 millas una delicia en la que el
paladar ya no siente el grano de polvo
se deshace en la boca y luego añadimos
manteca de cacao y chocolate a estas
máquinas antiguas llamadas con chad
horas estas máquinas antiguas hay muy
pocas si es que hay alguna porque hay
que darle tiempo al tiempo
nuestro praliné se mezclará durante 18
horas
la producción de la empresa se destina a
sus 30 tiendas
en las cadenas los empleados tienen
incluso derecho a dar una probadita de
vez en cuando
y como están
excelente lo mejor de lo mejor
bueno así ponen ambiente en la empresa
entonces si lo bueno es que no está
prohibido comerlo sino que se nos anima
a probarlo es un control de calidad que
dice
volvemos con philip ver nación para
descubrir la especialidad de la casa
para los palets dorados es una ganas
hecha con crema de leche encima por lo
que tiene un 45% de grasa es un bombón
de chocolate que tiene una vida útil de
un mes y así es todo está hecho a mano
de un gil y tuve al amor aunque la
técnica parece bastante sencilla se
requiere una ejecución perfecta para
hacer este chocolate
se ve que aún permanece la técnica
porque en 35 años hay una gran maestría
no se aprende en dos días
si parece sencillo pero hace falta la
técnica sí porque si se quita mucho se
ve la ganas y si no se quita lo
suficiente quedan con forma de sombrero
y así no se ve bonito
bajo el cincel de willy la estatua
finalmente comienza a aparecer
esta es mi cabeza ahora mismo está
realmente en mi cabeza sé exactamente
para dónde voy con esto
a nuestro artesano le gusta trabajar con
el chocolate en todas sus formas
hacer chocolate con los granos de cacao
es lo más importante es el arte del
chocolate esto es divertido es muy
divertidos entonces él ha dicho que
ahora se hace la misma cosa llevamos del
mismo
el trabajo del escultor está terminado y
el resultado es increíble el maestro
yoda en persona
ya sea chocolate negro o con leche
tallado relleno o en trozos los
chocolateros franceses compiten con la
imaginación para hacer que nuestras
papilas gustativas se deleiten